We always strive for authenticity with the character as much as possible.
bring him off the page of the comic book
and put him on screen in a way that would make that 3% of the hardest core fanboys pumped up
pumped up about it
miraculously, by pleasing them. I think we pleased a much wider audience as well
please don't make the supersuit green, or animated!
there were a lot of prototypes, when I put on the first deadpool suit
it was a tough thing to get right
a brilliant designer by the name of rush shanklev made it and he must have never slept
because we had such an accelerated schedule
but when I put that suit on the first time I actually wept when we got it right.
because it was though we just pulled it right out of our minds and on to the screen
so it was a pretty spectacular feeling to get that right, because that's a big part of it
I mean, that's that first impression everybody gets when they see photos of us shooting on the street
I would have to say that was a big one for us
Wait! You may be wondering why the red suit?
well, that's so bad guys can't see me bleed
this guy's got the right idea, he wore the brown pants.
I think the great hoax of Deadpool is that it actually starts off in a pretty emotionally depraved and devastating place
he's a character with cancer, so that sort of lays the groundwork for all these big comedic payoffs later on
what if I told you, we can cure you
notification squad that was the most serious
Deadpool trailer you're going to see is basically
for your consideration because the Oscar nominations
are coming up.
So Deadpool might win a couple really big
awards.
And to second big thing is that he's pushing
for a wolverine crossover movie.
So need to freak out about this there is a
new round of the Spider-Man giveaway to all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
So we'll talk about the award stuff first
because that's happening tomorrow night and
then we'll talk about the Wolverine team up
movie that Ryan Reynolds is trying to get
Hugh Jackman to come back for was a huge deal
all by itself to so like Ryan Reynolds says
they're basically breaking the glass ceiling
for comic book movies with this kind of nomination
with you know movie in the tone of Deadpool
there been a lot of serious comic book movies
everyone always wondered if Christopher Nolan
might win an Oscar for his dark Knight trilogy
because you even though all the films aren't
as good as the other films like dark Knight
for instance still stands is one of the best
comic book movies of all time.
So typically the people that vote on the different
awards for like Golden globes Oscars like
the really big movie awards do not like comic
book fair.
They tend to favor serious movies about serious
issues Hollywood itself if you ever watch
one of these awards shows it's kind of boring
because Hollywood takes itself so seriously
in one of the reasons why Deadpool deserves
to win an award is because it completely disrupted
Hollywood last year not just, comic book movies,
but just movies in general it is now the biggest
rated R film of all time in one of the biggest
X-Men films.
If not almost the biggest X-Men film that
foxes ever made.
So like Ryan Reynolds says a lot of that is
because of the script.
The script was really strong.
It just reinforces the idea that no matter
what your spectacles are you have to have
an awesome script just a hammer that home
the script itself was nominated for WGA writers
Guild of America award.
So great script great creative team behind-the-scenes.
It was also nominated for an award in editing.
So just like the way the film was made the
people that made it were all nominated for
awards.
So aren't you so happy now that most of that
team is coming back for the second movie.
Another was a lot of drama with the director,
we can talk about that more and Deadpool,
two videos this is mostly awards hype Deadpool
probably won't win just because like I said
Hollywood the people that vote on these awards
do not like comic book films, but because
it disrupted Hollywood, so much it deserves
to win, so let me know in the comments.
Why do you think that Deadpool deserves to
win an Oscar or Golden Globe award now it
has earned any Oscars nominations yet those
are due till next week.
So as I'm posting this video.
They have announced to's nominated for Oscars
it sort of been nominated for a couple Golden
globes which is happening tomorrow night.
Best motion picture and best actor for Ryan
Reynolds in a musical or comedy so I do think
because it's in the comedy category.
It has a much better chance of winning Ryan
Reynolds has a much better chance of winning
and if it were in the drama category that's
the really hard one to win.
That's the one that they take super seriously
like if your film isn't about some topical
world is been you're probably not can win
an award looping it back around to the Deadpool
two.
He said that basically like up until the time
that they were filming this promo.
They were working on Deadpool to hit me that
they stopped working on Deadpool to is gonna
take a little while longer before they start
shooting.
They have to announce who cable is playing.
So I'll be doing a whole bunch of Deadpool
videos once they start announcing stuff, so
next big thing.
We need to talk about Wolverine Deadpool team
up movie, what the hell's going on.
People were like oh my God is Logan going
to be like a Deadpool team up movie Ryan Reynolds
Hugh Jackman in the Logan director came out
and said no.
You know there's no Deadpool in this movie
because people were asking them is the gonna
be a crossover is there going to be a team
up.
They were basically saying that you know Logan
exist by itself is like a self-contained movie.
They didn't say anything about Post credit
scene, so everybody's expecting is that they'll
be some sort of Deadpool and tag that has
nothing to do with the Logan movie.
They just kind of like Tackett on at the end
of the film.
So no Deadpool inside Logan because the tone
is just so different from Deadpool that was
Ryan Reynolds big thing.
He's like I would love to do a Wolverine team
up movie but it would have to be its own separate
thing, so Hugh Jackman came back and was like
you know that sounds really interesting, but
it be kind of tricky because Logan is supposed
to be his last movie as Wolverine but never
say never because he is still super fit.
He could always come back and do more is the
for the last year he was saying this is his
last time to put the clause on.
And I think a lot of that had to do with the
creative direction of the character in the
X-Men universe of Fox, but now there's all
this talk about rebooting everything from
a creative perspective.
Brian Singer's left the franchise and their
sort of retooling the court X-Men movies before
they push forward into like a dark Phoenix
arc.
So when the way that Marvel sort of like separated
from the corporate parent in Marvel Studios
went off by itself Kevin fight he got a lot
more control the actor's got a lot more excited
about coming back to do more films.
I think the same thing will happen with Hugh
Jackman.
So it doesn't guarantee that the gonna do
crossover movie is that Ryan Reynolds is pushing
for one really hard after Deadpool to so will
do next week is a post another video for like
the top stories that I think they should do
for something like that but leave all your
Deadpool video request in the comments below
make a geek 6807 you this week's Spider-Man
giveaway winner be sure to private message
me on the back and my channel so I can get
your contact details.
This can be some more comic book stuff happening
this weekend but I will be posting some more
X-Men Legion next week.
So get ready for the Legion TV show that's
coming in February while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn all
about Thor Ragnarok, a.k.a. planet Hulk and
you can click here to rewatch the Logan trailer.
Thank you so much for watching I'll see you
guys in the next video!